[Music]
in freedom of speech news submitted by
Funkytown and man was jailed for
refusing to remove an indecent sticker
from his truck what did it say no I just
want your mom I'm a [ __ ] suck my
dick I don't know what is it what else
cheeks are cheap women are [ __ ] and
nothing but [ __ ] I don't know
anything else any other good I eat a
small grass or some [ __ ] I love it
that's disgusting no oh come on let the
guy eat some ass yeah B let him eat some
ass but that's not this [ __ ] I want to
see what does that mean about it look
how big it is too I think I don't like
that I don't like what guys have like on
their truckball I'm like why that just
shows me you have no balls just show you
that you don't need to date that person
exactly it's a warning shot is against
that see that's like the Confederate
fight you were like we should be in the
Confederate flag I'm like no I want to
know who not to hang out with yeah okay
we're warning
it helps me obviously that's what he's
about like you have dominate humbly that
you wear that around that's what you're
about this guy's about eating some
[ __ ] yeah I'm with it
I'm with you I've been converted alright
what if he means I like to eat donkey
he's alternative meat type of guy babies
yeah it's true maybe I picture like
those dudes that are like trying to be
like extra guys like they always have to
prove how guy they are yeah yeah yeah I
eat that ass and then like some guy
season two like so I heard you eat ass
wait what's the guy he doesn't you
there's this guy that's like how do you
describe him
you think very gaudy very flamboyant he
swears he's straight but he's like 400
pounds he has like his eyebrows look
like they were tattooed on so they're
like really sharp and like you rank
eyeliner to like a fat yeah and then
he'll have like this he looks like a fat
pirate okay you seen it yeah and then
you'll have like those really like style
lies like goatee or like these like
really like you would love this guy this
guy's great he's wearing a [ __ ]
Balenciaga robe robe and [ __ ] like
what if he's so extra he's like the
cheapest version of trying to be rich
yeah like you think he's gay but he's
talking about how he [ __ ] nothing but
beautiful models all the time and you're
just like no [ __ ] female what'd he
say about the people he's ok you know
like I like I'd love to see the pink of
the [ __ ] like you know when you spread
it it's like he's not it sounds like
he's imagining [ __ ] man's an [ __ ]
when you do that yeah only guys I know
whatever talk about how much they love
[ __ ] were gay later on they read that
came out his game I'm kidding
one of my favorite photos from that guy
is he has like California rolls and it's
like some cheap like sushi right you
know sushi everyday grocery store shoes
yeah every single day
yeah it's deliver you know everything
the best lips all his photos yeah I like
this guy so this guy here his name is
Dylan he's 23 years old from Florida and
he is fighting for his First Amendment
rights after he refused
when police or when police ordered him
to remove that sticker that's what they
meant by your First Amendment where's
this guy's gonna find me because I want
to [ __ ] put as much money into it as a
possibly human they can he's gotta lose
this case we was gonna lose he's not
offending anyone yeah I just think the
seat is too big it might be like
blocking his vision I think that might
have a ruled against something similar
to this which they considered a hate
crime we're in they had a dorm dorm room
and this kid every time you open up the
door his the the dorm that he saw across
from him or like the door that that's
right in front of him yeah there was
like a either a Nazi flag or a
confederate flag or something or
something in some racial slurs and stuff
like that because the guy that was
living there was a neo-nazi and in the
he didn't like that the black kid was
living across so when he opened it he
saw it and he would and in the the
neo-nazi kid was like whoa this is First
Amendment right but they they ruled it
as hate crime because there was no way
for him to basically
escape that and then it's like profane
right or whatever it is like he can't he
can't remove himself he has to witness
that every day
guess in this case it's just a quick
glance but at the same time it's a word
of it's a it's a profane word right and
then a kid might read it or whatever
that's exactly what the cops brought up
to him they'd be asked like oh you know
what if a kid sees this and then they
say ass on TV yeah what the [ __ ] are
they talking and you replied that oh cuz
they were like how would a parent
explained the sticker to a young child
and he was like well that would be up to
the parents yeah
and so he's saying that this this decal
he purchased it with a group of his
friends they all put them on their cars
and I cannot explain this to the cop
it's great you don't get it sir it's a
club right we bought eight of us all
about it yes I see the same thing so he
felt like he doesn't engage in that act
but it's just you can't back him up now
that he doesn't actually partake in this
but dude if I mean about it bro no no
listen just like I can find American
flag and I'm not in the military dude
you know I'm saying I don't have to be
all that without all he's trolling
that's a Steve man dude Ramon why don't
you feel cheated if you're a girl you
started dating him in your life wait so
you mean you don't really lick ass what
the [ __ ] dude that's why I [ __ ] what
on this date I thought you're gonna eat
that baby I would have been like dude
that's [ __ ] up man
that's like if a girl had a tattoo
that's be like I sucked good dick around
and then and the [ __ ] night comes
which is like actually not just did it
to troll so then you sue her for false
advertising he's willing to face jail
time to protect those who doesn't even
do it like you so go to dive in he's got
to fight for free speech it needs to be
kept alive somebody out there eats ass
and he's standing up for those people I
want to stand up for himself eating ass
you guys are down to ban his he fat
teddy bear you guys are down to ban his
statement from the back of his truck
he's so cute man dude hope you don't
come for my statements I personally
don't disagree I'm fine with it but I
understand the law I understand why the
law exists why does the law exist
no I'm serious no no because what cuz
this is what I was here I'm not
explaining this [ __ ] to my kid I don't
give a [ __ ] maybe I don't even have a
kid too
so why do I have to live in your world
where like your kids are gonna govern my
life
[ __ ] this [ __ ] yeah to me it depends on
it way to mass is considered a bad word
or not by the law and if it's not I
think it's a completely fine statement
to me it's it's like what Louie CK said
dude it's like how many people have
shitty [ __ ] kids it has it's so hard
to explain your shitty [ __ ] kid about
a thing that exists that's maybe
offensive in the world that you've got
to teach them about hold the horror of
to parenting that's the parents job like
if you go to Vegas and you see all those
naked chicks on those cars on the floor
you're gonna have to explain that [ __ ]
it's like crazy [ __ ] all over the place
but most of this is from the
judeo-christian [ __ ] said Allah you
have that's and it's a bunch of [ __ ]
you can't see ass it's so offensive see
ass oh my god I'm terrible just like we
can't see nudity on TV and [ __ ] even
though that's [ __ ] natural and normal
that's in life chicks can't have her
tits out at the beach make if they if
someone makes a dick statue right it's
the same thing that applies so anything
in the public space you can't do
anything that might be too clean right
because then it's gonna cause I guess
disorder in the community that's why the
law exists that's crazy
but it's not really something that I
agree with but I understand it cuz I can
Korea they have like the whole like
sexuality museum and like there's dicks
everywhere and it's like a family thing
that people go to there's no disorder
and constructive yeah that's a museum
right so intersection someone gets a
dildo and [ __ ] plasters it on the wall
okay right and then so that's a public
space surfaces cool exactly but it's a
public space and so I'm okay with it and
I could talk to my kids about it right
but there's so many other people from
different religions and whatever not my
problem I don't care
that's called a melting pot bro we're
all supposed to get along with the
driver that's generally what the who the
law is for its to basically cause less
of friction because it causes more
friction to have some [ __ ] chicks be
topless at the beach because somebody is
gonna be friction about
because you know I think they should be
top license or list me too but they
can't see but that's [ __ ] depending
on our state though that's like banning
ie tasks right it is [ __ ] but I
think morals and stuff like that like it
depends on the state in the majority
like what does the majority feel that's
for sure so for example like in France
or whatever topless beaches are okay but
it depends on where you're at right
certain beaches so that should be on the
next ballot where everyone votes is it
okay to have ie ass on the rear which
yeah it depends like like I know the
city of New York City specifically being
topless isn't illegal so a lot of people
do go topless or something like but if
you want to be tapas of the beach well
guess what if you want to be tapas with
beach I unexplained to my shitty kid
about why you're topless see how
ridiculous it is and then you're banned
from doing that but then a guy could
take off your shirt it's really morals
and law it all depends on whatever group
or culture you know so like whatever's
happening here no they did ask him if
you would be willing to remove one
letter of the sticker but he refused I
eat take the eye out then options
instead of just yeah then now he faces
charges for obscene writing on vehicles
and resisting an officer without
violence that's a charge you resist an
officer without violence he refused to
remove the decal I thought that was like
air fighting him like or by words so he
was booked into a detention facility but
he was released about an hour later when
his mom posted his $2500 his mom yeah
so he's like yeah she she supports her
son like any mother would good for her I
don't think for the kid for standing up
for himself
you know I've had even edgy enough to be
like this is a controversy yeah he said
he drove around for a whole week before
he got pulled over so do you know how
many people don't do [ __ ] about anything
about what they believe in and this
guy's actually taking a stand on for
that I don't think it's like that big of
a deal to stand for hit well no but it's
about the greater statement dude like I
said tapas at the beach like all this
other [ __ ] we got to fight back against
this religious [ __ ] that is pushing all
of us into corners that we don't want
yes on the ballot if there was a
decision to be made if I would allow
this or not and and vote for it to be
okay because I think profanity exists in
the world right and it shouldn't be a
criminal offense because George Carlin
had had a Standa and he actually went to
jail for it for using the word [ __ ] hey
so what it's just it's just stand up why
did why can't he be respectful see what
I'm saying that's that's why to me it's
all connected it's all the same thing to
me
[Music]
[Music]